hey what's up guys my name is HMO and
welcome back to my state plus plus
series today we'll be told me all about
the new keyword it's a boss boss and man
man does this meet talking about if you
guys missed my video yesterday about how
to create objects in C++ and the correct
way to accentuate objects and definitely
check that out cod that link there but
otherwise let's talk about new so the
new keyword is interesting because it's
it's actually quite deep a lot of people
write new and they don't really think
about it but there's a lot that goes on
and it's a really important that you
understand that especially since you're
programming in C++ the fact that your
prototype makes a bus bus means that you
should be caring about things like
memory and performance and optimization
all and all that because really if you
don't why are you writing C++ there are
so many other languages out there that
you can do especially now in 2017
why would you be writing to a bus bus
card unless you specifically need
performance or you specifically care
about everything that goes on and
understanding new is very very important
especially if you're coming from a
managed language like Java or C sharp
where memory is first of all cleaned up
automatically for you but also you don't
get anywhere near as many choices when
it comes to memory as you do in C++ so
for those who do know Java or C sharp
you're used to using new all the time
and when you're going to see bus bus
you'll probably think I yeah I can see
simple spots not that hard is the same I
mean there's a new key way I'll just
create a new class know check out my
video on how this and share classes if
you haven't already so the main purpose
of new is to allocate memory on the heap
specifically you write new and then you
write your data say whether that be a
class or a primitive type or an array
based on what you've written it
determines the necessary size of the
allocation in bytes for example if I
write a new int that is going to have to
request four bytes of memory allocate 4
bytes of memory once it has that number
it goes and it asks the operating system
what the I should say C standard library
I need 4 bytes of memory please give it
to me and that's where the fun begins
now we need to find a contiguous block
of 4 bytes of memory now of course 4
bytes of memory is very very easy to
find so there'll be Radek
quick allocation but it still needs to
find an address in memory where you have
full bytes in a row once it does that it
returns a pointer to that memory address
so that you can begin using your data
and storing data there and read me in
access of reading and writing and doing
all that fun stuff so you see how I just
like list it off like five steps or
something like that yeah
that's the primary takeaway from this
when you call new it takes time now I
did say that we had to literally look
for four bytes of contiguous memory it's
not really like it's not like it it
literally searches our memory just in a
row like a laser being like a cater we
have four bytes free no I'll look on the
next slot there's something called a
free list which actually maintains
addresses that have bytes free not a
story for another video but it's not
like it might not be as slow as you
think it's obviously written to be
rather intelligent but it is still quite
slow but that's the primary takeaway
knew basically finds a block of memory
that is big enough to accommodate our
needs and then gives us a pointer to
that block of memory let's take a look
at some cards what I've got over here is
a very basic class has just got a string
name that's it I'm going to scroll down
over here and we'll take a look at the
new keyword first and foremost just like
we create integers normally by doing
this we can also choose to actually
dynamically allocate that memory and
credit on the heap by using the new
keyword so what we can write is int
pointer B because remember as I said new
returns a pointer to the memory that
you've allocated equals new int and
that's it that is a single for byte
integer allocated on the heap and this B
is storing its memory address if I
wanted to allocate an array instead then
I would ask where brackets and just type
in how many elements I wanted so in this
case 50 which means we need 200 bytes of
memory 50 times 4 for being the size of
each integer if we wanted to allocate
our NC class on the heap by the new key
where we were write code like this or
this alternatively we don't need to use
parentheses for this the default
constructor but we can and I usually do
if we wanted an array of entries instead
week
do that by just using square brackets
and there we go that's basically new
right that's how you use the new keyword
let's talk about it a little bit more
with classes the nuclear what does two
things it doesn't just look at entity
see how big an she is in this case it's
a string so that's I think like 28 bytes
or something like that don't quote me on
that I'm just guessing from memory it
multiplies that by 50 and it asks for a
block of that many bytes in the case of
an array though you'll actually get a
block of 50 entities just continuously
in memory so this is actually kind of
like allocating 50 entities on the stack
just in a row it's a little bit
different because you're still allocated
on the heap but each entity in this
example won't really be in another
memory breast you have your block of
memory which is 50 entity it's just just
in a row if we go back to two this just
being a heap allocated single entity
object then by writing this new keyword
we not only allocate enough memory on
the heap to store this anta see we also
call the constructor that's the other
important thing that the nuclear work
does it not only allocates the memory it
also calls the constructor now behind
the scenes all new really is and you can
see what I've done here is I've just if
you right-click on you you can go to
definition and you'll see what this dot
operator new actually is first of all
you'll see that it's an operator new is
just an operator just like plus or minus
or equals it's an operator which means
that you can actually overload the
operator and changes behavior we'll talk
about overloading operators very very
soon link in the description card on the
screen all that jazz but second of all
you can see that is literally just
function and this is the size that it
takes that's how much it allocates it
returns a void pointer we might talk
about void pointers in a separate video
but basically a void pointer is just
it's a pointer with no time a pointer is
just a memory address so of course it's
like pointers really need a type it
needs a type for you to be able to
manipulate it probably the way that you
want to but at its core a pointer is
just a memory address it's just a number
so why would it need a specific type
like int or double or entity but anyway
you can see that we return a void
pointer so it returns a pointer it so
takes in a size and it returns a point
to that allocate block of memory but
what new actually does behind the scenes
and strategies speaking this is actually
dependent on the state plus plus library
so of course Bureau your own save us
plus compiler with your honesty of us
loss library because theoretically make
it do anything you wanted but usually
usually pulling you will call the
underlying state function malloc which
that's for memory allocate and what this
will actually do you'll note is taking a
size of how many fights we want and
return a void pointer so that's really
all it does so that being said this code
is actually kind of equivalent to if we
just written malloc sizeof entity like
that and then of course cost this back
into an end to see something we wouldn't
have had to do in C but we do in C++ but
the difference between these two lines
of code the only difference between
these two lines of code is the fact that
this will actually call the entity
constructor whereas what this will do is
purely allocate the memory and then give
us a pointer to that memory not calling
the constructor you should not be
allocating memory tables like this there
are some situations in which you might
want to do that we might talk about them
later but for you right now if you're
watching this video because you don't
know what I pretty new is using you
because this of course won't call the
constructor and it's also way poor code
and it's just harder to read and this is
really the way that you should be doing
it the last thing that I'm going to
mention about new for today is that when
you do use the new keyword you have to
remember that you must use delete so
once we allocate all these variables
like B and E we have to use the delete
keyword which is also an operator if you
go to the definition for that X is also
an operator text in a block of memory
size it's just a regular function which
calls the C function free and actually
frees the block of memory that was
malakut this is important because when
we use the new keyword the memory is not
released it's not marked as free and
it's not put back into that free list so
that we can call new and allocate it
again until we call delete we have to do
that
manually there are of course a lot of
strategies in simple spots to automate
this in some form and there are simple
strategies like kind of scope based
pointers and advanced strategies like
reference counting we'll get into all of
our stuff in the future but just keep in
mind if you use me like this in a wrong
way
you have to use delete and I do plan on
talking about the intricacies of all
this memory management in the future
once we actually start working on a
project and writing code which is
actually going to be very soon so get
excited everything will be revealed I'm
sure and you'll see many examples in the
case of B because this was allocated by
using the array of credit keep in mind
by the way that this new that takes in
an array of peretta is actually a
slightly different function if we
allocate using new with square brackets
we should be calling delete with square
brackets like this because there is a
delete operator with square brackets
like that okay so that's another rule if
you allocate using new with square
brackets because you've allocated an
array delete using the square brackets
if you don't then just use whatever
square brackets one more thing that new
actually supports is something called a
placement in U and that is where you
actually get to decide kind of where the
memory comes from so you're not really
allocating memory in this case you're
just calling the constructor and
initializing your entity in a specific
memory address and the way you do that
is just by writing parenthesis like this
and then specifying a memory address
such as well B in this case I mean it
would theoretically work because I'm
assuming that entity is gonna be less
than 200 bytes definitely well because
it's just a string but yeah this it's
gonna confuse like all this code and
really really we'll talk about placement
new in the future in more detail on how
you can actually use at optimizing a
code quite a bit but for now I just want
to show you what the syntax kind of
looks like in however anyway I hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did you
can have that like button you can also
help support this series and make sure
more awesome episodes are made by going
to patreon account or search the channel
I've got a discord server there'll be a
link in description below we can talk
about all this stuff
patrons get special like server roles
and also a special channel where we
actually talk about these videos and
plan the next
it's kind of like right behind the
scenes and very details very cool
so definitely check that out and become
a pic home and help support this series
I will see you guys in the next video
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]